[Música]
una vez unos chicos de secundaria me
dijeron
si vemos uno de gorrita nos cruzamos de
vereda
en otra ocasión escuché que una señora
dijo yo solo me ocupo de mi marido y de
mis hijos
y un alumno uno de los de gorritas me
dijo un día
pero seguro que a cabo alguien para
tener lo que tiene
como podemos aprender a convivir si
somos actuamos o pensamos tan distinto
como podemos encontrarnos y concertar la
diversidad
podemos entender que somos responsables
de construir la sociedad que queremos
hoy quiero contarles nuestra propuesta
que desarrollamos hace 20 años y que
llamamos porque esta escuela porque si
hacemos orquestas pero las cultivamos
como una escuela de vida
esta propuesta la vivimos hoy niños
jóvenes y adultos de toda la argentina
pero es una metodología que aplicamos
por primera vez en chascomús una hermosa
ciudad de la provincia de buenos aires e
incluso por esto fue declarada capital
nacional de las orquestas infantiles y
juveniles
trabajamos desde tres dimensiones a la
vez
la individual la familiar y la
comunitaria
nosotros las integramos para hacer
música juntos pero es un modo de vivir
que sirve para la escuela en el ámbito
laboral el club los amigos el barrio
para que vean de qué se trata vamos a
armar una orquesta ahora mismo
lo primero es que los chicos estén y
para eso hay que ir a buscarlos nadie
puede amar lo que no conoce por eso hay
personas que no pueden saber que quieren
les voy a presentar a jade una de mis
primeras alumnas y ya maravillosa
profesora multiplicadora que va a ser la
tarea que hacemos todos los días
enamoraron de la propuesta porque esta
escuela a personas que nunca se
imaginaron estudiando estos instrumentos
bienvenida jade
[Aplausos]
qué sorpresa jade va a ir a buscar a dos
miembros del público que van a ser
participantes integrantes de nuestra
orquesta escuela del teatro colon
muchas veces para incluir no alcanza con
abrir las puertas para que vengan ni con
que sea gratis por eso nosotros vamos a
buscarlos en nuestro auto que se fue a
estar talando o en lo que podemos
pero siempre lleno de instrumentos a
sociedades de fomentos comedores hogares
a las plazas y a distintas escuelas
conformando el 80 por ciento de nuestro
cupo con diferentes sectores
también cuando creamos una orquesta
escuela ofrecemos una inscripción
abierta para cubrir el 20% del cupo
restante con niños y familias que eligen
hoy la educación musical
así buscamos una verdadera integración
social
quien se anima a inscribirse para formar
parte de esta orquesta escuela el teatro
colón de buenos aires a ver levanten la
mano
cuantos valientes a ver
señorita
bienvenidas
ahora sí
cáritas réplicas
lo que está sucediendo ahora entre jade
y nuestros tres chelistas nuevos es la
clase personalizada en este espacio
trabajamos la dimensión individual y la
clave es la mirada miramos a cada
persona como un individuo único con
muchísimos talentos para cultivar
este momento es revelador
es donde creemos tanto tanto en nuestros
alumnos para que ellos crean en sí
mismos eso sí los garantes del proceso y
del resultado somos nosotros los adultos
responsables
nuestro desafío como docentes es ver
cómo acompañamos a cada persona la
famosa equidad
para eso a veces el 99% de nuestro
trabajo es antes de llegar al atril
antes de poder iniciar un proceso o esto
simplemente se refleja en la elección de
una obra musical que tenga que ver con
afinidades con talentos pero todo por
supuesto nos tiene que permitir trabajar
lo que buscamos que aprendan para su
desarrollo personal y colectivo
en la clase personalizada algunos de
nuestros alumnos tienen quizá por
primera vez la mirada de un adulto para
buscar su voz encontrarla cuidarla y
disfrutarla como un tesoro propio y como
un tesoro para compartir
como me dijo un día una alumna mi música
es algo que nadie me puede sacar
porque si no encontramos nuestra propia
voz
si no nos conocemos a nosotros mismos es
muy difícil que podamos estar bien con
los demás cuando vienen a la orquesta
los chicos se integran a una familia de
instrumentos ahí aprenden a construir
experiencias con un grupo de pertenencia
vamos a conformar la familia de los
violonchelos bienvenidos los
violonchelos
hola felipe
alina natalín cocina y por celina
conocieron a sus amigos
miren qué hermosa familia de
violonchelos
para trabajar la dimensión familiar
la segunda clase la otra clase que
proponemos desde la orquesta-escuela es
el taller de fila es donde crecen juntos
los violines la percusión o los
violonchelos como en este caso
la familia de instrumentos es el primer
espacio de encuentro entre pares
es donde aprendemos esos saberes
transversales que tanto nos exigen los
tiempos de hoy y de mañana como el
trabajo en equipo
es donde fortalecemos nuestra identidad
es donde mi voz interactúa y se integra
con otras voces distintas a la mía pero
con lo común a otros
en este espacio construimos nuestra voz
que no falta
aprender a vivir en comunidad
uniendo nuestra voz personal a la de
nuestra familia en un todo más amplio
que nos desafía a desarrollarnos con
otros distintos a nosotros entonces una
orquesta puede convertirse en un lugar
de promoción donde aprendamos a hacer la
mejor versión de nosotros mismos siendo
parte de una comunidad diversa
para nosotros la excelencia es una
búsqueda una búsqueda que merece hacerse
en el presente de cada uno y de todos
esta metodología además permite que los
chicos sean parte importante desde la
orquesta desde el primer momento
por eso nuestras obras musicales están
intervenidas para que sean multinivel
esto es que puedan ser parte de una
misma orquesta chicos que por primera
vez tienen un cello en las manos junto a
otros de un nivel técnico superior lo
importante es que están construyendo
juntos
participando colaborativamente como nos
demostraron los chicos
sí no
bien
y
[Aplausos]
hoy solo en chascomús más de 7000 chicos
ya fueron parte de la orquesta
chicos que soñaron y hoy desarrollan sus
proyectos de vida
que formaron hermosas familias y hoy
como padres traen a sus hijos
algunos son músicos profesionales otros
además son maravillosos profesores
multiplicadores
quizás no somos sólo una orquesta sino
una red de orquestas en todo el país
donde aprendemos a convivir en armonía
disfrutamos
nuestra diversidad de nuestro mundo y
diverso
y donde todos
todos sabemos que es mucho más divertido
que si son amos todos iguales
ah
[Música]
e
a
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por qué
[Música]